In this lecture, we'll
see how optimization
can be used to construct
sports schedules.
Specifically, we'll
introduce the method
of integer optimization.
Sports is a $300
billion industry.
This is twice as big as
the automobile industry
and seven times as big
as the movie industry.
This includes tickets for
games, team merchandise,
salaries for players, etc.
Almost every single
country participates
in the sports industry.
For this industry to
remain so large sports
teams are very important.
They key revenue for sports
teams comes from TV networks.
TV networks paid
$513 million per year
for English Premier League
soccer, $766 million
per year for the National
Basketball Association, or NBA,
and $3 billion per year for
the National Football League,
or NFL.
These TV networks are
paying such large amounts
to ensure that they will have
a good schedule of sports games
to convince fans to
tune in and watch
the games on their network.
In addition to the TV
networks, good sports schedules
are important for
other reasons too.
One is that extensive traveling,
caused by a poor schedule,
can cause player fatigue, which
can reflect badly on the team.
Also, ticket sales tend to
be better on the weekends,
so teams like to
have games scheduled
for weekends to
increase revenue.
Additionally, it's better
to play division teams,
or direct competitors
for playoff spots,
near the end of the season since
teams have more information.
For these reasons and many more,
everyone in the sports industry
is incentivized to have
a good schedule of games.
All competitive sports
require schedules
defining which pairs of teams
play each other and when.
Until recently, sports
schedules were mostly
constructed by hand.
This is incredibly
time consuming.
With just 10 teams, there
are over one trillion
possible schedules, where every
team plays every other team.
There are many
constraints defined
by the TV networks,
teams, cities, and others.
TV networks want games
to occur at prime times,
like in the evening.
Teams want games
on the weekends.
Cities want games
that don't conflict
with other major events, etc.
This requires looking through
all trillion possible schedules
to find one that satisfies
all of the constraints.
For major league baseball,
a husband and wife team
constructed the
schedules for 24 years.
They mostly built
the schedule by hand
and used a giant wall of
magnets to schedule 2,430 games
each year.
Not only is this
approach time consuming,
but it's very difficult
to add new constraints.
If one new constraint is added
that might make the schedule
infeasible and the process would
have to start all over again.
There have been many
interesting constraints
that have been added
by interesting people.
In 2008, the owners
and TV networks
were not the only ones who
cared about the schedule.
President Barack Obama
and Senator John McCain
complained about the schedule.
2008 was an election
year and President Obama
and Senator McCain were the
leading presidential nominees.
The Democratic and Republican
National Conventions
conflicted with
the game scheduling
so the schedule
had to be adjusted.
After that was settled, the Pope
complained about the schedule.
The Pope visited New
York on April 20, 2008.
He traditionally always
holds mass in Yankee Stadium,
but a game was
scheduled that same day.
The schedule had
to be readjusted
to move the Yankee game.
These are just a couple
examples of the wide variety
of constraints that
have to be accounted
for when building
a sports schedule.
Recognizing how difficult it was
to construct sports schedules
by hand, in 1996
a company called
the Sports Scheduling
Group was started.
The founders were Doug
Bureman, a former baseball vice
president, and three academics--
George Nemhauser, Michael
Trick, and Kelly Easton.
Instead of generating
sports schedules by hand,
they use a computer.
They've been scheduling
college sports since 1999
and major league
baseball since 2005.
They rely on optimization to
build the schedules, which
can easily adapt when new
constraints are added.
In this lecture, we'll introduce
one of the techniques they use,
called integer optimization,
to construct a sports schedule.